foreign
[Applause]
these are all my rowdy and normal New
York friends tonight and thank you for
being here
now tonight bombshell new evidence in
the Joe Biden bribery Scandal
allegations uh and tonight we have
receipts now the house oversight and
accountability Committee just released
these another bank memo it details
payments to the bidens let's see from
Russia Kazakhstan uh Romania Ukraine and
China most of those countries really
love us don't they they made a fortune
uh Beyond 20 million dollars they were
able to trace chairman Comer will join
us in a few minutes and talk about it
and just thenews.com's John Solomon will
be here to break it all down but let me
sum this up for you and this is serious
this is massive sums of money and Hunter
Biden at the height of his crack
addiction and prostitute addiction was
raking in millions and millions of
dollars from corrupt foreign Nationals
now these are in many cases corrupt born
countries and our number one number two
geop political foe Russia and China or
the opposite China and Russia and then
facilitating meetings and phone calls
and other favors between these corrupt
foreign Nationals and then Vice
President of the United States of
America Joe Biden in other words that
was Hunter's job connect them to Joe the
big guy the guy who was given half his
income to Pops anyway Hunter at the time
wasn't admitted crack addict and now it
begs the question what did Hunter the
crack addict personally do or even have
to offer these countries for what is now
tens of millions of dollars what was he
giving them what work did he perform or
the grandchildren that they've traced
money to what did they do for the money
that was funneled to them through these
shell corporations or quote llc's that
had no businesses in them now Hunter
admitted he himself had no experience in
energy at all and no business with EXP
variance with countries that were paying
him all these millions
um you know so what were the countries
paying him millions of dollars for what
did he do for that money now Joe's
Proclamation both as candidate Joe Biden
and now President Joe Biden he said over
and over and over again that he never
once discussed foreign business dealings
with Hunter his brother or quote anyone
else for that matter that has now been
proven to be a massive life we know
through text messages we know through
emails we have photographic evidence we
have eyewitness accounts and now we have
tonight bank records but according to
Joe Biden none of this ever happened and
today again our own peter Ducey asked
very important questions he vehemently
denies yet again ever talking business
with Hunter but yet he's meeting with
Hunter and Russian and and Kazakhstan
oligarchs and all these rich people from
all these countries that don't
particularly like us and then by the way
he exploded at our very own peter Ducey
Peter deserves a raise for this but
daring to ask this question
there's this testimony now where one of
your sons former business associates is
claiming that you were on speakerphone a
lot with them talking business is that
what whatever
and I know you'd have a lousy question
well what do you it's why is that a
lousy question thank you because it's
not true
well that's what Devin Archer said that
would be Hunter's business partner that
would be the guy that you sent a note to
personally you know handwritten with a
little note at the bottom of it a very
own peter Duce is going to join us in a
minute he'll respond tell us what was
going on behind the scenes great
question so Joe Biden is flat outlined a
lie that he repeats with regularity as
president here's Joe every time he was
President lying to you
Shakedown text message
were you sitting there were you involved
were you no
[Music]
the only thing they can do is make up
things about my family it's not going to
go very far
oh it's going far anyway a liar repeated
over and over again during the 2020
campaign he continues the big lie while
continuing sadly to yell at my friend
and colleague Peter Ducey and other
reporters take a look
Mr Vice President how many times have
you ever spoken to your son about his
overseas business dealings I've never
spoken to my son about his overseas I
have never discussed with my son or my
brother or anyone else anything having
to do with their businesses period And
what I will do is the same thing we did
in our Administration there will be an
absolute wall between personal and
private uh and and the government do you
stand by your statement that you did not
discuss any of your son's overseas
business yes I stand by that statement
now only in the last two and a half
weeks did that evolve into I never was
in business with Hunter oh a very
different scenario ask yourself uh well
what do you trust more career politician
like Joe Biden a Serial plagiarizer a
habitual liar uh or hard evidence in the
form of photographs text messages and
now bank records because tonight we now
have access to some of the most
compelling evidence to date a new report
from the house committee on oversight
and accountability has now identified
quote over 20 million dollars in
payments from foreign sources to the
Biden family and their business
associates for the Democrats who believe
this is all some kind of Illusion well
here are the bank records take a look on
your screen right there this shows a 3.5
million dollar wire from the former
first lady of Moscow a Russian oligarch
that went right into an account owned by
Hunter Biden and Devin Archer and by the
way a short time later and she also
invested what 120 million in real estate
Joe Biden then Vice President of the
United States after the three and a half
million dollar wire had dinner with the
Russian oligarch Elena batarena is her
name in Cafe Milano beautiful Washington
D.C just as bad a sewer as New York City
and also last week Devin Archer he
confirmed the same Russian oligarchy did
indeed invest 120 million dollars in
Hunter's real estate fund okay meanwhile
following Russia's invasion of Ukraine
this particular Russian oligarch Elena
batarena received no sanctions from the
Biden Administration I guess just a
lucky coincidence I don't know now in
2014 and 2015 then Vice President Biden
also allegedly attended dinners with his
sons Kazakh business partners oddly
enough in April of 2014 one of those
Kazakhstan business partners wired a
whopping 142 300 into one of Hunter
Biden's accounts by the way a mere
coincidence I'm sure the exact price of
a brand new Porsche sports car that
Hunter purchased I'm sure it was
accidental that figure now what did
Hunter at the time in admitted crack
addict do to earn that money what did
all of these countries expect for the
millions and millions and millions of
dollars we now know that the bidens were
paid now why did Joe Biden lie over and
over again and say never ever discussed
any of these matters and yet Devin
Archer says over 20 times that he can
recall he called into meetings with with
these foreign business associates anyway
now we have bank records showing
millions of dollars in payments from the
Ukrainian oligarch you know the guy that
owns parisma Holdings once again Hunter
facilitated discussions between Barista
execs and DC and a short time later Joe
forced out the prosecutor that was
investigating Barista oil the oil and
gas giant in Ukraine uh and his own son
for corruption they will be investigated
this after barisma was begging Hunter
please we need DC help on the issue on
this issue and others will help came
when Joe Biden gave the prosecutor or
the government leveraged the billion of
your tax dollars and gave them six hours
to fire the prosecutor and Son of a bee
they fired that prosecutor and Hunter
continued to get paid money of which he
admitted he had no experience on Good
Morning America and by the way the
prosecutor Hunter who was described on
the 1023 form by the barisma executive
they thought Hunter was dumb and stupid
the guy actually said he thought his dog
was smarter than Hunter
so not making it up this is all one big
coincidence I'm sure they were just
looking for a crackhead that they just
felt like that giving millions of
dollars to and it wasn't just one
country it was numerous countries or as
the committee reports quote President
Biden's family is the vehicle to receive
bribery payments the report continues
indeed the law recognizes that payments
of payments to family members to
corruptly influence others can
constitute a bribe so keep in mind who
the bidens were conducting business with
we're not talking about deals with the
Royal Bank of Canada or Switzerland or
Japan instead Hunters raking in money
from a Russian oligarch from Moscow
another oligarch from Ukraine a Romanian
businessman convicted a bribery a
Chinese partner suspected of economic
crimes and bribery and a Kazakh
politician convicted of treason and
according to emails and tax from
Hunter's laptop Hunter was forced to
hand over 50 percent of his salary to
Pops he hated it had to pay for all of
pops's home repairs and he bitched about
that and another email listed a 10 stake
in one deal for the big guy Tony
bobolinski said the big guy was Joe
Biden everybody knew it never mind the
credible FBI Source in the 1023 form
accusing Joe Biden of accepting a five
million dollar bribe from Barista execs
and it will take us 10 years to find out
how they paid him now we're just
supposed to act like this is all
business as usual all while Joe Biden
lies to our faces and we have all this
evidence if there are any Democrats left
in Washington with any Integrity they
need to speak out this is not business
as usual in fact it reeks of nothing but
corruption hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else